To update my project,
I first modified the get forecast method
to future detect the cache's object.
When it supported, I request the weather
forecast data from the cache and
call update forecast with the response.
I modified updateForecastCard
to make sure that the old data
doesn't clover the new data.
By checking the time of the data that's
currently stored versus the new data.
If it's older, we just bail out.
I also tricked the date element to store
the raw data and make comparison easier
and added a date-dt=0 attribute
to the element in index.html.
Then, in the service worker,
I bumped the cache name and
added a new data cache name for
storing the data that also means,
I needed to tweak
the activate event handler so
it doesn't delete the data
cache when it runs.
Finally, in the FetchEvent handler
I checked if the requested URL starts
with the weather API base URL.
If it does, I fetch the data
then clone the response and
put it into the cache and
finally, return the response.
Otherwise, we handle the request
just as we did before.
If it's in the cache,
we return the cache version, otherwise,
we get it from the network.
If you got stuck or
want to see exactly what I did,
the solution I built is linked
in the instructor notes below.